empezaremos ahora un viaje en el mundo
de la estadística que en realidad es una
manera de entender o de meterse de lleno
con los datos así es que estadística
tiene que ver con datos y para empezar
este viaje en el mundo de la estadística
estaremos haciendo lo que se denomina
estadística descriptiva si tenemos una
gran cantidad de datos y queremos
establecer algo acerca de esos datos sin
dar todos los valores como podemos de
alguna manera describirlos con un
conjunto más pequeño de números en eso
nos vamos a enfocar y una vez que
construyamos un conjunto de elementos
básicos de estadística descriptiva
entonces empezaremos a hacer diferencias
acerca de los datos estaremos haciendo
lo que se llama estadística inferencial
estadística inferencial podremos sacar
conclusiones hacer diferencias muy bien
aclarando esto pensemos cómo podríamos
describir los datos supongamos que
tenemos un conjunto de números que
podemos considerar como nuestros datos
quizá estamos midiendo las alturas de
las plantas en nuestro jardín digamos
tenemos seis plantas cuyas alturas son
cuatro pulgadas tres pulgadas una
pulgada seis pulgadas una pulgada y
siete pulgadas
imaginemos ahora que hay una persona en
otro lugar donde no puede verlas que
quisiera saber qué tan altas son tus
plantas y lo único que requiere saber es
un número que de alguna manera
representa las distintas alturas de tus
plantas como harías esto bueno te
podrías preguntar cómo podría encontrar
ese número quizás quiero un número
típico o quizás quiero un número que de
alguna manera representa la mitad quizás
requiero el número más frecuente o
quizás quiero un número que represente
el centro de todos estos números al
responder a esta pregunta con esos
números estaría respondiendo de la misma
manera como lo hicieron las gentes que
desarrollaron la estadística descriptiva
como lo hicieron empecemos con la idea
del promedio promedio en la terminología
usual promedio tiene un significado
preciso cuando mucha gente habla acerca
del promedio en realidad están hablando
de la media aritmética la cual
revisaremos en breve pero en estadística
promedio significa dame el valor típico
o dame el valor del medio
estos son o en realidad es un intento de
encontrar una medida de tendencia
central tendencia central de nueva
cuenta tienes un conjunto de números que
quiere representar con un único número
que llamamos el promedio que puede ser
el número típico o el número de en medio
o el centro de estos números y como
veremos hay en realidad distintos tipos
de promedios y el primero es aquel con
el cual estás probablemente más
familiarizado cuando se habla de
promedio de calificaciones o de la
estatura promedio en realidad nos
estamos refiriendo a la media aritmética
déjame escribirlo en amarillo media
aritmética media aritmética aritmética
puede ser un sustantivo el área las
matemáticas que estudian los números o
puede como en este caso de media
aritmética ser un adjetivo calificativo
y este es simplemente la suma de estos
números dividido entre y esta es una
definición desarrollada por el ser
humano sumamente útil la suma de estos
números dividido entre el número de
números que tenemos entonces cuál es la
media aritmética para este conjunto de
datos calculemos la esta va a ser igual
a cuatro más tres más uno más 6 +1 más 7
dividido entre el número total de datos
que son 6 tenemos 6 datos divide entre 6
y esto va a ser igual a 4 37 más 186 14
más 115 más 7 22 es igual a 22 vamos a
checar 4 37 18 + 6 14 más 115 más 7 22 y
está bien 22 6
y esto lo podemos escribir como un
número mixto que sería 22 entre 6 esa 33
enteros 4 sextos lo que es igual a tres
enteros dos tercios o también en un
número decimal que es 3.6 periódico
podemos escribir la de cualquiera de
estas maneras pero este es un número que
es representativo estamos tratando de
obtener una tendencia central de nueva
cuenta insistimos en que esta es una
construcción humana no es como alguien
que encontró en un documento religioso y
dice aquí está la manera de calcular la
media aritmética este su definición
estricta no es un cálculo puro como así
decirlo como cuando se descubrió el
cálculo de la circunferencia un círculo
a partir de observaciones de la
naturaleza es una construcción humana la
cual se ha encontrado que es sumamente
útil bien hay otras maneras de calcular
el promedio o encontrar el valor típico
o el valor del medio la otra manera de
establecer un valor típico de medida de
tendencia central es el valor denominado
la mediana luego escribir luego escribir
en otro color voy a utilizar el rosa
mediana y la mediana es literalmente
buscar el valor de enmedio si ordenamos
los valores de menor a mayor la mediana
es el que se encuentra ubicado
exactamente a la mitad de los valores y
cuál es la mediana para este conjunto de
datos
bueno calculemos la vamos a ordenar este
conjunto de datos tenemos un 1 luego
otro 1 luego 3 luego 4 luego 6
finalmente 7 lo único que hice fue
ordenar de menor a mayor este conjunto
de datos y cuál es el número de en medio
de este conjunto de datos bueno notamos
que es un número par son 6 datos y no
hay exactamente un valor de en medio más
bien hay dos valores en medio el 3 y el
4 y en el caso en el que tenemos dos
números en medio tenemos que tomar la
mitad entre estos dos números de hecho
tenemos que tomar la media aritmética
entre estos dos números para encontrar
el valor de la mediana así que la
mediana va a ser la mitad entre 3 y 4
esto es 3.5 entonces en este caso la
mediana es por tanto 3.5 así que si
tienes un número par de edad
la mediana es la media aritmética entre
los dos valores del medio o la mitad del
camino entre los dos valores del medio
si tenemos un número impar de datos es
mucho más fácil de calcular y para que
veamos esto déjame darte otro conjunto
de datos pongamos que nuestro conjunto
de datos es nose y te lo va a dar y
ordenado empecemos con el 0 el 7 el 50
10.000
un millón
millón realmente un conjunto extraño de
datos pero en este caso cuál es la
mediana bueno en este caso tenemos un
número impar de datos y es fácil elegir
cuál es el valor del medio nuestro valor
del medio es 50 que está por arriba de
dos valores y por abajo de dos valores
exactamente a la mitad así es que en
este caso la mediana es 50 ahora la
tercera medida de tendencia central y
esta es la medida que en la vida real
muy probablemente se usa - es la moda
una medida que la gente tiende a operar
que suena como si fuera muy complicada
pero veremos que se calcula de manera
inmediata y de hecho es la medida más
básica de la tendencia central así que
la moda es el número que aparece más
frecuentemente en un conjunto de datos
si todos los números aparecen el mismo
número de veces no existe un número que
aparezca más frecuentemente entonces no
existe la moda pero dada esa definición
de moda entonces cuál es el dato más
frecuente en el conjunto de datos
original en el conjunto de datos que
tenemos aquí bueno tenemos un 4
3 tenemos 2 unos tenemos un 6 y un 7 así
es que el dato más común que aparece más
frecuentemente es el 1 entonces la moda
el número más común el número más típico
es en este caso 11 así que hemos visto
distintas maneras de calcular una medida
típica la de en medio una medida de
tendencia central que se calculan de
diversas maneras y a medida que
estudiamos más estadísticas nos daremos
cuenta que estas son útiles para
distintas cosas esta se usa muy
frecuentemente la mediana se usa cuando
tienes un valor muy extremo que pudiera
sesgar la media aritmética la moda
también podría ser útil en ese tipo de
situaciones sobre todo si tienes un
número que se presenta mucho más
frecuentemente en fin ahí lo dejamos y
en los siguientes vídeos vamos a
explorar la estadística aún más
profundamente